-Salut Romain! Dis-donc, tu fais quoi fin Juin?
-Bah rien pourquoi ?
-Alors tu réserves ton 22, 23 et 24.
-Tu m'amènes en croisière?
Non pas vraiment
L'année dernière je suis allé au Hellfest . D'ailleurs j'ai croisé pas mal d'entre vous et c'était très très cool!
C'était tellement cool que cette année eh bah j'y retourne et j'y retourne avec Romain!
Il est content
Et d'ici là on va vous faire une  série de vidéos avec mes petits conseils pour bien préparer l'événement
Alors même si vous, vous comptez pas y aller, je vous conseille d'être attentifs
parce que ce qu'on va vous raconter c'est valable pour tous les autres festivals
...Festivaux? Fest...
C'est valable pour tous les festoches!
et de toute façon c'est toujours bon à savoir.
Mais comme on parle bien que de ce qu'on connaît vraiment
j'vais vous parler du Hellfest
la fête
la musique
les activités récréatives
les animations sportives
les rencontres
les danses folkloriques
mais aussi la chaleur et le soleil de l'été qui débute
Autant de petits et de grands bonheurs dont il faut absolument profiter à fond
pendant un, deux, trois voire quatre jours sur place.
Et qui veut voyager loin ménage sa monture.
Alors soyons clairs je vais vous parler de santé mais tout ça c'est extrêmement festif.
Le Hellfest c'est ultra bon enfant, c'est jovial, les gens font attention les uns aux autres
comme dans une grande famille, donc aucun souci évidemment.
D'ailleurs, en terme de sécurité, de secouristes, etc c'est du top niveau, mais ça on en reparlera.
Mais c'est comme pour toutes les compétitions sportives si on veut être au top le jour J
l'important c'est la
Parce que ça serait quand même con d'laisser un petit pépin physique gâcher un truc qu'on attend toute l'année
donc d'ici fin Juin je vais vous faire plusieurs vidéos pour bien préparer l'événement. On va parler de headbanging,
on va parler de la trousse de secours à emporter avec vous et on va parler de tout ce qu'il faut faire et de tout
ce qu'il faut pas faire avant et pendant pour passer le meilleur fest possible
et évidemment si vous avez des questions vous m'envoyez un p'tit mail à
On est partis pour faire un bon p'tit bout de chemin ensemble donc on y va tout de suite.
Ah oui et en attendant bah mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous bien.